le variant omicron qui rebat les cartes
et qui pousse à accélérer la mise en
place du pass vaccinale on en parle avec
notre éditorialiste alexis poulain un
bonjour alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous et de répondre à nos questions donc
un conseil des ministres extraordinaire
lundi prochain on sera le 27 décembre
initialement la présentation ce texte
sur le pacs vaccinale c'était prévu le 5
janvier et là on se dirigerait vers une
promulgation entre le 10 et le 15
janvier pour comment expliquer une telle
précipitation bon je crois que le
gouvernement essaye d'aller très très
vite pour
surfer sur la vague parce que sur au
micro ondes jusqu'à présent c'est pas
grand chose si ce n'est qu' il est
beaucoup contagieux pour la dangerosité
apparemment ce qui leur sort d'afrique
du sud c'est que ce n'est pas si
terrible que ça pareil pour la grande
bretagne donc l'idée c'est de pousser
les gens à avoir cette troisième dose
quand même eu un dessert en grande
bretagne un don avec le virus pas
forcément du virus mais on peut tourner
le la question dans tous les sens
clairement il ya une fébrilité le l'idée
d'aller très très vite d'éviter
peut-être une mobilisation de
l'opposition ne pas y passer encore une
fois les contre-pouvoirs et le parlement
il ya quelque chose d'incroyable quand
même le fait que cette crise sanitaire
qui n'en est plus une la pandémie est
devenue une holding enfin on vit avec ce
virus maintenant ça fait deux ans on
nous a dit tout et son contraire on
devait faire dodo soir impasse vaccinale
se passe vaccinale maintenant on peut le
désactiver si on n'a pas la troisième
dose et puis après quoi sanitaire pas
encore pas rationnel il déjà vaccinale
quasiment aussi les apparemment les
français sont d'accord je sais pas
comment c'est possible d'accepter un
poste vaccinale sachant que la stratégie
vaccinale jusqu'à présent a montré ses
limites elle n'est pas suffisante tous
les médecins le disent ça veut dire quoi
ça a montré ses limites ça veut dire
qu'on va être confiné en janvier comme
les pays-bas l'ont annoncé
parce évident à ce serait un échec du
tout fonctionnel mais c'est de toute
façon le tout vaccinal n'existe pas
c'est un échec tous les médecins vous le
disent y compris du conseil sanitaire de
la haute autorité de la santé vise le
vaccin est un outil dans cette lutte
contre le virus mais il ne suffit pas la
preuve combien de double vacciner
combien même de triple vaccinés qui ont
le virus le patron de bio
explique que oui ça protège peut-être à
70% de mikron mais ça n'empêche pas de
l'avoir maintenant aux microbes si vous
regardez les symptômes c'est le nez qui
coule c'est le mal de gorge c'est le mal
de tête c'est à peu près un gros rhume
sauf que peut-être sept acolytes qui
peut tuer comme vous le dites une
personne est décédée en grande bretagne
les données et afrique du sud sont
plutôt rassurantes en réalité sur la
létalité de ce virus et en globalité si
on revient à ce qu'elle coronavirus là
encore 0 12% de la population française
qui est touché un taux de mortalité de
quasiment -2 1% et on en est à vacciner
les enfants dès 5 ans et a poussé
impasse vaccinale à l'ensemble de la
population certains médecins commencent
à s'interroger sur ces stratégies
justement pourquoi vouloir absolument
cette troisième d'eau si elle ne protège
pas suffisamment ou si elle protège de
manière très légère dans le temps c'est
à dire seulement quelques mois puisqu'on
parle de booster maintenant quasiment
tous les tous les trois mois tous les
quatre mois donc il ya un vrai problème
de santé publique aujourd'hui qui
devrait sortir du cadre du conseil de
défense sanitaire en dix ans un peu plus
être décidées sous le sceau du secret
défense on doit maintenant avoir un
débat scientifique sur la réponse à ce
qui est maintenant une non plus une
pandémie mais on va vivre avec ce virus
comme tous les autres corona virus de la
grippe donc soit on a un accent qui
fonctionne et d'autres vaccins arrivent
à leval vénat etc novavax qui a été un
peu vague qui a été approuvée hier par
le relatant leur père mais comment
voulez vous pousser les gens à une
troisième nous sachant que récemment on
poussait les gens une troisième dose
avec du moderna et puis on a dit que
modern a été potentiellement dangereux
pour les moins de 30 ans notamment dans
le cadre des myocardite c'est à dire que
être comme ça traités comme des cobayes
pour voir comment fonctionnent ces
produits ça n'incite pas vraiment à
aller se faire vacciner
tous les trois mois et pourtant c'est ce
que voudrait le gouvernement en
extorquant c'est pour moi c'est de
l'extorsion vaccinale puisque ce n'est
pas une obligation c'est une obligation
déguisé ce que ne devait pas être le
passé ni terre si le conseil
constitutionnel revenez sur son texte
est bien en l'occurrence se passe
vaccinale ne pourrait pas exister donc
je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe dans
notre pays dans lesquels passent
vaccinale pour l'instant n'existe pas
c'est encore le pass sanitaires et au
sujet du pass sanitaire il ya eu 180
2000 faux-pas sanitaires ni selon le
recensement est fière du ministère de la
santé
d'où le rappel à l'ordre du premier
ministre jean castex qui appelle à
intensifier les contrôles notamment dans
les bars les restaurants les hôtels
le gouvernement qui durcit le ton avant
noël est ce que c'est de bon ton c'est
scandaleux enfin je veux dire depuis
cinq ans la france et neurasthénique on
est dans un pays d'une tristesse infinie
je vous rappelle qu'on a quand même
gagné la coupe du monde qui se rappelle
la coupe du monde de foot elle a été
volée sur les champs-elysées il ya aucun
moment de liesse de joie hélas dès que
vous avez des fêtes on interdit le
rassemblement alors on a fermé les
boîtes de nuit d'abord maintenant on va
interdire les feux d'artifice de nouvel
an on explique aux gens comment faire
chez eux ne pas être plus de 6 les alors
le l'an dernier il fallait laisser papy
mamie sur le balcon c'est anne ils ont
le droit d'être là mais au bout de la
table il faudrait pas trop qui
s'infectent le masque de manière
perpétuelle je crois qu'il pourquoi les
français sont si fatigué c'est qu'il ya
une main délitement des solidarités un
délitement des moments de joie de
communes de communauté tous les lieux de
vie étaient montrés du doigt les
restaurants les les boîtes de nuit les
bars etc les théâtres mais rappelez-vous
la milice du travail qui disait on
notera pâle copie de travail bon ben
maintenant on est en train de discuter
d'un pass vaccinale pour aller
travailler c'est n'importe quoi le
syndicat refuse elle m'a exposé
également ses réticences à ce sujet
plus de 3000 patients en réanimation
selon les mots tout à l'heure de
gabriella talent à la mi-journée une
contamination sur 3 par rapport à
omicron est-ce que omicron va faire
s'écrouler le système hospitalier
français mais non si on regarde les
chiffres actuellement
d'afrique du sud ou de grande bretagne
les pays bas qu signer ou qui ont au
micro-ondes
n'explose pas sous des cas qui vont à
l'hôpital d'ailleurs gabriela talent se
garde bien de parler des malades enfin
très peu y parle aujourd'hui des 3000
qui sont en réanimation mais sur le
nombre le taux d'incidence c'est
simplement le nombre de cas maintenant
ce qu'il faut regarder de près c'est le
nombre de malades graves combien sont
ils avec omicron combien sont ils on n'a
pas les chiffres aujourd'hui et puis la
courbe des âges également est ce qu'on a
raté de quelques quelques configurations
par rapport à la protection des
populations les plus fragiles comment ça
se passe mais quand vous avez un décret
du ministère santé du 13 décembre qui
interdit de prescrire certains
médicaments ou uniquement dans des cas
particuliers notamment l'azithromycine
signé par olivier ferrand c'est à dire
qu'on empêche certains traitements et on
empêche la liberté de prescrire des
médecins est en ville pour se focaliser
uniquement sur une stratégie vaccinale
où les anticorps monoclonaux qui coûte
très cher et qui sont inefficaces là
encore contre mikron donc on est là dans
une stratégie qui n'a rien de sanitaires
qui est entièrement politique qui est
d'ailleurs totalement le l'idée de
bruxelles puisque cela von der leyen a
fait une conférence avec les différents
chefs d'état a expliqué que le pass
vaccinale européen ne durerait que neuf
mois si vous n'avez pas la dernière dose
demande et donc on est là dans 1 1
sorte de volonté politique de pousser
des gens la vaccination d'éviter qu'ils
aient des traitements ou des recherches
sur les traitements certains
faiseurs qui arrive oui une pilule
fighter mais des labos français de
travailler sur des anticorps monoclonaux
dual ils n'ont pas eu les moyens vous
aviez d'autres laboratoires dans le nord
de la france notamment à l'institut
pasteur qui n'ont pas eu non plus les
fonds nécessaires pour faire leurs
recherches vous avez une volonté de
couper les fonds pour certaines
recherches pour que tout soit fait qu'il
n'y ait pas d'autre choix que celle de
la vaccination avec pfizer ou moderna
puisque les autres vaccins sont
quasiment hors course aujourd'hui mais
s'il ya de nouveaux vaccins qui arrive
sans compter les vaccins comme
ce pique nique v qui ont été interdits
de territoire européen pour des raisons
géopolitiques donc on est vraiment là
dans un choix politique qui fait qu'on
pousse les gens à un pass vaccinale qui
va à l'encontre de notre constitution
qui là encore les syndicats patronaux
dit ce n'est pas aux entreprises de
d'imposer une politique de santé ou même
de savoir quel est le statut sérologique
ou vaccinale des employés on peut pas
que c'est peut-être entrer dans ce monde
là sans se poser des questions pourquoi
le fait-on merci alex et poulain d'avoir
répondu à ma question je rappelle que
vous êtes éditorialistes